joining us here on the rich eisen show
is one of my favorites from the las
vegas raiders he made the second team
all pro he's a pro bowler he is a
self-made man
out of uh
eastern michigan
ypsilanti michigan is where he got his
college ball in fourth round pick out of
the raiders now a grown-ass man making
life very difficult for quarterbacks in
the league's max crosby how you doing
max
doing great rich i appreciate the the
amazing introduction it's the truth this
is a fact these are facts okay um
how how has the that loss sat with you
over the last couple days
max
ah it's been you know it's been weird uh
that's probably the best word i can use
i've still been in the facility every
day since the
since the season ended it just
it's been heartbreaking because
what we went through and how much
how much we put into it um and just to
end on a last play like that it's just
been
it's been tough um i just want to keep
playing football that's really that's
really all it is for me and i know i
know the guys wish the same
what was the toughest aspect of the
season
for the raiders with a lot of tough
aspects that you know many teams don't
know how to face because they don't
usually have to face them
max
yeah you know there's so many things
that i can point to but
there was just a lot of
ups and downs and on you know
nothing guaranteed you know there was
you know if we got a new coach
we had you know new players
injuries
constantly um but the one thing that
stayed constant was just everyone's
attention to detail
and
the will to win you know everybody
wanted to just continue to play even
when
we were six and seven and
just got beat by like
a hundred points by the chief
you know we could have we could have
just said all right well you know we'll
see what happens we'll get ready for
next year but
we went on the road beat cleveland
came home beat denver
went on the road beat indy and then
finished it at home and beat the
chargers you know all against a really
good team so
it's just
a clip a collective group of guys that
like i can't even describe how how proud
i am of this this team and coaching
staff it's been it's been one hell of a
ride so um then i'll ask you for a
couple of reactions here uh max crosby
uh the general manager who drafted you
gave you the opportunity along with
gruden who's no longer there as we know
but uh mike mayox fired how does that
sit with you
max yeah you know it's it's it's tough
man uh mike you know the things he's
done for me
like you said he drafted me um he's done
so much for me always looked out for me
constantly
just being there um it's him his family
you know they've always always been so
good to me and my girl and my family and
i can't appreciate how much i appreciate
him you know he's uh
you know it's crazy we just i was just
in his office two days ago had an
amazing talk and then the next day i got
the news so you know we had a good talk
yesterday and
you know he's gonna be good you know
he's uh he's a great dude and i can't
you know i can go on all day but he's
just
he's he's a special guy and i just
appreciate you know everything he he did
for me and in this organization you know
he's been awesome what did rich versace
do
uh this year that kept everything afloat
max
um you know rich
rich is one of a kind you know he's
you know everybody's been asking what's
going to happen and
everybody knows my vote
and this i made that very clear you know
i love rich i think he's the best man
for the job and
he's come in and done done such an
amazing job we've won 10 games with a
team that's
had tragedy lost
everything you can imagine um and he's
found a way to get a group of guys to
come together and win football games
in january and december um which is rare
uh so
you know rich
rich is he's the real deal you know he's
he's a leader of man and that's that's
all you can ask for is it true he wrote
handwritten notes after the loss to
cincinnati to members of the team did he
do that is that a true story um
he
he does that
he does that before every game
as long as he's been you know been here
he he will put a note in your locker um
before you know a game and you'll just
you know still say whatever but you know
obviously that's private but sure yeah
he i had one that was before cincy that
was you know it's before he's been doing
it for years so
you know obviously he's he's the guy
that doesn't want to bring attention to
himself and
somebody i think it was his daughter or
something took a picture of him and rex
put it on her facebook kind of leaked
and he was upset about it he's like man
you know i don't want to make it seem
like i'm vouching for myself that you
know he's one of those guys he's so
humble and
uh it's just incredible so i just you
know i like to take the time to show him
his appreciation because he'll he'll
never do it for himself
i think there's like 19 eyes in vesaccia
so yeah i mean okay so um
and again i know you say it's private
but can you give me a general gist of
what it's like when you go to a lock
your locker and you get a handwritten
note from from your
head coach what it's what it what it
portrays what that means
max
yeah you know it's just special when you
have the guy who's the head coach the
leader of an nfl team and you get a you
know you get a letter from him he's i
literally just talked to him so
i'd go up and walk in his office like
it's you know he's my friend
i could really have those conversations
i always
that's you know you don't find that
often and
it's just special you know when you have
something like that in the building
already you know uh
in my opinion you should keep that um
you know but what do i know i just you
know i show up and do my jobs the best
of my ability and
um you know it's just special having
rich here he's a he's a special guy well
you you know i mean like when we spoke i
think uh a couple of times ago on a zoom
prior to the monday night game in
los angeles uh that was a week three i
think and and and who knew at the time
that was going to be gruden's last game
as head coach with and for your team
um you were saying that that chemistry
was better than ever that guys were
pulling together and pulling for each
other more than ever before
so you know and and the way things
actually played out with henry ruggs and
arnett the fact that you guys all did
hold it together
and won games made the playoffs and
actually had a possession to try and win
it
you know or tie it
you you would know if versace is the
right guy to be honest with you max
you know
yeah you know having you know rich
um just in a building like even when he
wasn't the head coach you know he was
he was always the guy he can go to you
know he was always there for me he was
my guy that on the coaching staff that i
trusted you know to go and have those
conversations with so you know coach
gruden i'm not taking anything away from
coach gruen you know he knows i love him
uh
and
everything like that but at the end of
the day the players are the ones playing
um and rich cares about the players
number one always you know that's his
always that's what he always says he's
like the guys in the locker room are the
most important they're the one out there
making plays and coach bradley says the
same thing he's always preaching that
um so yeah you know at that time
if you know
if we have guys that are playing for
each other no matter what happens and
all the adversity um
you can't win 10 games you know with
guys
uh with guys that don't care about each
other you know at the end of the season
you know we go to cleveland it's
freezing cold for six and seven
uh the only way we can do that is if we
have guys playing for each other and
that's what rich preachers and all these
guys preach and in this locker room you
know no matter what what happened we
just kept rolling with the punches and i
think people got to see that this year
pro bowler max crosby of the las vegas
raiders here on the rich eisen show uh i
got uh questions to ask you about two
moments uh that the whole country's been
talking about over a span of a few weeks
um and let's take them in order first
one the game against the chargers
you're on the sideline you're watching
time take down you know a tai sends you
the playoffs you know what ty sends the
other team to the playoffs
timeout gets fired off by the chargers
the general sense is that that that
that uh that time out by brandon staley
led to
you know
no kneel down were you guys gonna kneel
down if that timeout didn't get fired
off best to your knowledge max crosby
i uh you know i've heard so many uh
different stories and opinions on this
yes um what's yours but at the end of
the day
i think we were going to attempt the
field goal regardless um that's my
opinion you know i've heard a million
different opinions on it
but in a game like that with how much
work we had to put in to be in that
position
to let
them make the playoffs as well and just
accept the tie i just find that hard to
believe
so i know coach rich and he
he's a winner i know these guys in the
locker room where you know we have
winners uh so
i especially you're playing the division
rival just in my opinion i don't think
we would have just left them off because
they'd be like all right we'll just tie
and not risk it you know we were there
to win the game and send them home so
you know that's what we did and
i'm glad that glad that we did that yeah
because if that was me i would be right
up next to versace certainly if i'm not
on the field right and the offense is on
the field you're david where were you
were you listening in on the
conversations
i'm on the bench exhausted i played i
think not close to 90 snaps
so i was just looking at the game like
oh we're going to go down josh is going
to you know
josh is going to run the ball we're
going to go and kick the field go win
the game and that's what we did so i
really at the time i had no recollection
of
of that so
yeah i was just thinking we're going to
win the game
all right and then the play that
everybody's talking about more recently
because you wound up because you won
going to cincinnati joe burrow throws
one to taj boyd there's a whistle uh did
you guys did
bass did do did uh part of the team stop
playing or stop the you know running as
hard as possible because you thought the
play was over you heard the echo of the
whistle
in that moment max
that's another there's always
controversy with us
um just say the least but
yeah um during that play i was in
pursuit of the quarterback
and
you know i'm
i'm just running the you know run of the
running after joe burrow and
in my in my view
it looked like he ran he stepped out of
bounds
so
when that happened i don't know if he
did or not like i saw the replay i don't
think he did but it was very close
and so when he almost stepped out of
bounds he launched the ball and the
second he left his hand the ref right
there blew the whistle because he saw
what i saw it was close and it looked
like he stepped out right so we heard
the whistle and then all of a sudden i
looked back and he caught the
you know the receiver caught it but it
looked like the db stopped so that was
just my opinion then i saw the replay
and i'm like oh yeah the whistle blew
you know literally our guys stopped and
it looked like the bengals guys thought
it was over as well
um
but then all of a sudden they just said
signal touchdown and i was yelling at
the rap saying like no way blew the
whistle he blew the whistle regardless
if he stepped out or nine
i thought they should have stopped it
but what do i know you know
it definitely seems to get to the
quarterback right it definitely seemed
again it's tyler boyd my bad that he he
he did seem like the ball had already
maybe
you know uh crossed the plane of the
goal on the way to boyd's hands when the
whistle blew but you you were right
there so as soon as you saw the foot go
down near the end the uh the boundary
you heard the whistle max crosby that's
what you're saying yeah that's that's i
just assumed he was out and they blew it
dead and even if he didn't you blow the
whistle i thought it would be another
play or just redo the play or whatever
but
you know it didn't that didn't happen
but at the end of the day it was what it
is over with you
you know wish we could play a better
game and get them back because i really
do believe we were the better team we
just we didn't play our best football on
saturday max crosby here on the rich
eisen show last one for you you let's
talk about you uh and what you have
become and you know you were very
emotional about making the pro bowl and
what it meant to you
personally uh what what do you want
people to know about what you have been
through and how you can be used as a
model
to fight through all that
max crosby
yeah you know uh for me um i've been
through a lot
from my childhood
it's been been through a ton
growing up i didn't have the best life i
was
a wild a wild kid to say the least
went through a lot of ups and downs
battle demons
but one thing that stayed true was i
never left lost sight of what i wanted
to become
i always wanted to be
in the nfl i wrote it and told my
teachers every single teacher from
middle school from elementary school to
high school everyone i kept the same
goal
and even though i had some ups and downs
addiction all type of stuff i never lost
sight of that
and once i got my life together i
started seeing
seeing the brighter side and like just
in my third year i'm 24 years old and
i'm a pro bowler i'm an all-pro and
that just gives me more motivation so
just for people out there
you can do whatever you want to do
people before this season were writing
articles saying
telling you know telling asking this
match unique bench you know we signed
this guy this guy is max bench now is he
going to lose his job i kept everything
so
i just know personally
everybody's going to say whatever they
want to say about you but if you come in
and put the work
you can become anything you want and for
me it's special because i know i'm just
getting started and you know i just want
to go to a whole nother level next
season and so how did you pull your life
together
max like what happened did something
happen that made you realize that you
need to
clean up or sober up in a way
at all yeah i think it was just uh it
was
at the end of the day it was just uh
it became repetitive um with my decision
making and
what i was doing it just wasn't working
um it kept getting progressively worse
um
drinking more partying more
not you know not as dedicated
you know to my
to my craft and
you know all that football is my number
one so
if i were to lose that i don't you know
i
that's kind of what it was for me it's
like all right i'm either gonna go and
have fun and
do all these crazy things and be done
and be forgotten or i can make a
decision right now and change my life
go get clean
and do what i'm meant to do and i feel
like i was put on this earth to play
football
and be an example for people that went
through what i went through um and
that's that's what i'm doing right now
and i just want to continue to to grow
and take that to higher and higher
levels um every single day so that's the
thing i can tell people is
if you got a plan to do something to do
something you have goals like
i used to think such you know big
picture like i always like i want to do
this i want to do this but i didn't take
care of the day-to-day and for me i just
i try to stay in today
make the most out of my 24 hours
every single day and just be positive
and be a positive light for somebody
else and i've been doing it one day at a
time and
it's it's it's showing um and i just you
know i feel like i'm just getting
started and it's gonna be you know
bigger and bigger every day max crosby
what a season what a great season what a
great career you're building and it's
been a pleasure to get to chat with you
throughout it you have a spot here
whenever you want you know that but uh
congrats on it i'm really uh i'm really
thrilled for you and i hope you get what
you want in terms of your coach and
everything else thank you
absolutely thank you grace i appreciate
it brother right back at you at crosby
max with two exes on twitter i follow
him you should as well that's the great
max crosby
what a story what a message
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here